let me ask you this because i know
you know you had experienced the
colombia [ __ ]
and then [ __ ] with empire and then
the drake record happens and then that
goes over to warner a little bit
and yeah i'm sure you know at any given
time
you could have signed with anybody what
made you want to stay independent
stay down with ghazia and the team at
empire uh
i just had more freedom like i had just
way more freedom like
you know i felt like i was you know just
running my own show you feel me and i
was just doing what i knew
worked it they was just funding whatever
i wanted to do you know what i'm saying
so i was like
i really had no reason to assign to a
major uh
because like they was you know i had i
had like videos with like other labels
and stuff like that
like major labels right you know what
i'm saying guys i know was able
was willing to you know saying talk to
them same numbers but stay
independent and i was getting most i was
like wow why would i you know what i'm
saying can you tell us who was like
number two you were considering
uh i think it was it was a it was a it
was horrible between like a
republican or republican or
empire oh republican i mean that's true
i mean republic is like the superstar
label yeah yeah